اجراءات اقل حده هكذا وصفت تويتر السياسه
الجديده المتعلقه بالتجاوزات على الموقع
من ضمن الاجراءات الجديده سيتم قبل حظر
الحساب الحد من وصول التغريدات التي
تنتهكوا سياسه منصه او مطالبه المستخدمين
بازاله هذه التغريدات قبل الاستمرار في
استخدام الحساب موضوع تعليق الحسابات او
حتى فكه وحضرها دائما ما يحايره ملكه
تويتر الجديد الى مصر الذي تعهد ان يكون
الموقع منبر للحريه لكنه ايضا يواجه
اتهامات بانه سيمنحو المتطرفين والاراء
العنصريه مساحه اكبر على تويتر فهذه
الخطوه تاتي بعد تعرض مصر لانتقادات بسبب
تعليقه حسابات العديد من الصحفيين بسبب
الجدل حول نشري بيانات عامه بشان طائرته
الخاصه لكنه اعاده تفعيل الحسابات في وقت
لاحق ايضا تاتي هذا رفع الحظر عن حساب
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب بعد
اجراء استطلاع راي ايد فيه المستخدمون هذه
الخطوه بفارق ضئين وخلال الشهر الجاري
قعدت وتر تفعيله
10.000 من الحسابات الموقوفه التي تعود
ملكيه بعضها لاصحاب نظريات المؤامره او
اليمين المتطرف